على مساحه واسعه
عمقه كان سبعه كيلو
على محافظه الى جانب كاران رشاثر عليها
وعثمانيه
ومراطيه واضيما
وديار بكر هو اوقفه
تسبب في هدم وفي ادراك في جميع هذه
المحافظات
كما اثر تاثيرات ربما هي اقل في المحافظات
الابعد لكن هذه المحافظات العشر الاساسيه
هي المحافظه التي شهدت الاضرار فعليه قويه
جارتنا الجنوبيه السوريه في شمال سوريا
ايضا هناك شهاده المنطقه هناك
اضرار كبيره
دولتنا منذ اللحظه الاولى للزلزال تحركت
بكل قوتها وبكل اجهزتها
فالمحافظات
استنفرت كل قوتها داخل حدود محافظه
اداره ولايات هذه المحافظات تم تعيين عشره
ولاه محافظين اخرين لتقديم الدعم
والمسانده ايضا والى جانب ذلك مؤسساتنا
التي
تعتني مباشره بقضيه الكوارث مثل افاد
والهلال الاحمر توجهت مباشره الى تلك
المنطقه ايضا
القوات المسلحه التركيه
وغيرها من المؤسسات التي لديها خلفيه حول
اداره الازمات والكوارث من هذا النوع تم
توظيفها في تلك مناطق
اولويتنا كانت ولا زالت اعمال الانقاذ
حاليا يوجد تسعه الاف عنصر ضمن فرق
الانقاذ
هذا الرقم وصل ولا زال يتزايد عبر
المساعدات التي تاتي من المناطق المجاوره
المحافظات التي شهدت اضرارا كبيرا من هذا
الزلزال
[موسيقى]
ومتى جعلها من انقاض بقي تحتها الكثير من
المواطنين تستمر اعمال انقاذ اولئك
المواطنين الذين هم تحت الانقاضي ونحن منذ
اول لحظه
ومنذ لحظه حدوث الزلزال تواصلنا مع
الاجهزه المحليه ومع الاداره في انقره
وتابعنا المرحله اولا باول
مكتب مركز التنسيق في انقره تحرك مباشره
برئاسه نائب رئيس الجمهوريه السيد فؤاد
اوكسايد والوزراء ايضا توجهوا الى
المحافظات للاشراف على الاعمال اعمال
الانقاذ في محلها
من المحافظات القريبه وحتى المحافظات
القصيه
استنثرت كل
الامور من مساعدات ومن فرق انقاذ وفقا
لمخطط
افاد تم توجيه فرق الانقاذ بمسانده من
شعبنا
في هذا الفصل في هذا الموسم الشتائي
البارد
وفي ليله في وقت الليل كل هذه العناصر
كلها
صعبت من الوضع وزادت الوضع صعوبه لكن
الجميع
قام برده الفعل اللازمه بسرعه ودون
التباطؤ حاليا
هناك حاليا 912 مواطن توفي ما زاد على 500
خمسه الاف مواطن جوبح في هذه الاصابات
التي هدمت زادت على
2800 مبنى هدم بالكامل
العديد من المباني تلقت اضرارا للاسف لان
الانقاض لا زالت
اعمال الانقاذ المستوى لا ندري الى متى
الى اي مدى يمكن ان تصل هذه الارقام
تمنياتنا هو ان تكون هذه الكارثه قد انتهت
وطبعا في هذه المرحله لتذليل
المواصلات والاتصال يجب العمل على هذا
الملف خصوصا وبالتالي
فالابقاء على الطرق المؤديه الى مناطق
الكوارث مفتوحه
استخدام وسائل المواصلات والاتصال فقط في
الاوضاع الضروريه هذا مهم جدا وعلى
الاشخاص والمؤسسات الذين سيذهبون الى
مناطق عليهم ان يكونوا في تنسيق دائما مع
افاد
اما المساعدات التي ترسل دون تنسيق فهي
تسبب اضطرابا في المنطقه وفي التنسيق
وتعسر وصول المساعدات الى مستحقيها وبشان
المساعدات الدوليه
نواصل تواصلتنا مع الدول الاخرى الى جانب
الناتو والاتحاد الاوروبي هناك خمسه
واربعون دوله قدمت طلبا لتساعده في هذه
الكارثه
لمواطنين الذين توفوا في هذه الكارثه
العظيمه واسال الله شفاء للجرحى نحن كدوله
وشعب بوفلا
سنتجاوز هذه الازمه ان شاء الله
نحن خمسه وثمانون مليون مواطن اليوم هو
يوم الاتحاد
دولتنا
بهم كل انحاء دولتنا اسال الله السلامه
لمواطنين
ادعو الله بذلك شكرا جزيلا
اذا هذه كلمه